[Applause]
what a treat to have you here tonight
we're still one to dance
what a great movie so Maria Navarro was
selected to be one of the interviewees
by Lorde a party sure hood should be
here not me interviewing you and the
great cinematographer now director for a
number of years with Leo Garcia
so it's terrific to have you both
tonight Maria came from Mexico to be
with us tonight and it Rodger Garcia is
one of our local boys by now right so
can you tell us first of how you met we
were he was assistant photographer and I
was assistant director in a film called
I'm well about the scheme that's right
that's right and we became friends and
we said that whoever was not assistant
but that chief for the next time we
would work together and we made Maria's
first movie Lola right before this this
was the second movie very good so you
are both coming from film school which
is an interesting outcome because you
were basically working outside of the
traditional structures of the Mexican
film industry was it easy to put this
production together it's never easy to
make an you feel so was difficult but at
that time it was difficult to do it
against the the usual way of making
films with not with the the Union we
didn't work with the Union and being a
woman
but other than that it was a very
pleasant shoot and we were very happy
during the shooting we were friends and
we enjoyed it very much
yeah I mean you know the Mexican film
industry had been huge in the 30s 40s
50s 60s and out of it had come you know
very strong system of unions which
ironically we all supported because we
supported organized labor but these were
unions that wouldn't let any new people
in so it was very difficult and I think
dance owned belonged to a group of films
that you know that the cultural you know
the cultural institutions in Mexico were
supporting for people to make films who
had word in not in these unions and new
directors and we were part of that new
group know that included you know Maria
and Luis Estrada whole bunch of people
who made their first movies at that time
what's interesting when you see this
your second film is that it was so
different from Lola your film of 89 two
or three years later you come up with a
sort of change of strategy from some
something that had been done much more
outside of the industry a very personal
film about a mother searching for
something and taking care of a little
girl so how do you switch gears with
this field a little bit
the thing about Lola was that I loved
that film I think we did a good work
together also but it was perceived as a
feminist film and for example of the the
film critics wrote very horrible things
about that film I felt totally I felt
completely understood by the female
audience but very rejected by by other
people by
and the strategy changed because say I
told my sister I was writing with her at
the time those two films we wrote
together and I told her let's make
another woman's film but they will not
know they will not know her until it's
too late and it worked we did exactly
that I think and so did you get the idea
for the second film for this is such a
personal film the LA Times review said
it was the the view of someone who was
very independent and had a great vision
you had glowing reviews for this film in
the u.s. thank you I
I've always loved dancing I went dancing
a lot and when precisely when when we
were talking about making a very well I
was also sad a tough film to watch it
was about difficult things and it had to
do also with the the the earthquake of
55 the the all the scars that were left
in in the city in Mexico City and we
really wanted to make a very happy very
joyous film the next time dance on and I
told my sister let's go dancing every
week twice or three times a week and see
what comes out of that and going to the
dance hall during a lot of time I
completely fell in love with it and so
on I thought I do not want to make a
film about the woman who dances but I
want to make a film about dance on
exactly than son because it is a
wonderful music it is a wonderful dance
it embodies for me a perfect way of
talking about sensuality in the Mexican
way about sexuality in the Mexican way
about
courtship men and women and the dance on
arrows have a saying they say they told
me at the very beginning they told me
that in dance as well as in life
the man commands and the woman obeys and
I loved it as I as I thought I will make
a film about that in which in dance yes
it's wonderful but not in life but the
interesting thing is you subvert all
that because she is completely by the
end of the film it's phenomenal how you
begin and end the same way but there's a
world in between and she has changed
right so explain to us anagnorisis
because that was a beautiful wink of the
eye to European culture and the Greek
language that's a running joke in the
film
well anagnorisis is my sister studied
theatre and she told she always was
talking about that moment in which the
characters finally realized something
and for the moment which holy realizes
that that young man is not for her that
was the Agnon anagnorisis moment and we
put that the ice cream little car
because we were joking all the time we
were having fun all the time I haven't
seen it for a while but yeah I mean
obviously when you shoot a movie and
then when it's been edited you see many
cuts and then you do the color you do
the sound you know you get so saturated
but now you know it had been 25 years
since I saw the movie so it was you know
I found it super enjoyable I mean I can
say as an audience member not as someone
who worked on it I was saying to Maria
that I thought you know she did an
extraordinary job even ten minutes into
five minutes into the movie I said to
her the world is so specific and so
genuine you know when you're putting
something together you don't you know
sometimes you don't really see what's in
front of you but
for me it was a terrific journey and she
managed to you know to bring together
into what I mean Maria Rojo who plays
Hulya was a major star at the time as
was the hotel lady
Carmen Salinas I mean we're talking to
big Mexican stars to get you know who
are acting with first-time actors
non-actors people who are dancing people
who lived in that hotel
someone Maria would see on the street
and she said you come here you play the
homeless guy and it all came together
incredibly seamlessly I mean it it's
it's like a like a super romantic
documentary almost that's that's what it
looked like to me today
so what's interesting is that the way
you follow it became so obvious this
time seeing it here with the audience
the the care the love you have for the
dance on arrows how did you bring a
really go to film those interviews of
people dancing so true to life the real
thing during the time I was preparing
the film and writing the film and go and
I was going dancing every week I made
friends with all these danced on arrows
both of these people who dance so I
really knew them personally I knew them
by name when I invited them to appear in
the film I would tell them please use
use this lovely golden shoes that I love
so much or wear this red dress that is
my favorite of your dresses so I really
knew them they were not extras they were
my friends might and scenarios friends
they were always trying to convince me
to do the dance and let us have
different groups sex sex sex yeah like
like that you know the tango dancers
have these clubs so their clique
cliquish they have their cliques and and
the people who dance the berries which
is my favorite
from cerrado the very slow and tight
than type of dance on are always
fighting with the ones that that dance a
more open and colorful and so on so they
would be all the time telling me that I
should make the film right and dance
only with them whoever whoever they were
so I really knew them they were my
friends we joked I love the way they
think and for me they they all an bodied
something that was very precious to me
and I I think it is in the film to have
a big love and respect for my culture
and for my heritage and and our a
sentimental education as Mexicans and
and - I wanted to portray a Mexico that
was going away and I wanted to keep it
alive in my film so I was looking for
that all the time trying to tell
everybody this is my country this is
what I love and this is who we are and
that kept me going
in choosing every person every moment
every every detail as as Rodrigo said so
this it's interesting because you
compare it with the sensibility of a
Cuaron and I was a listener it when they
portray you know that the popular world
the world of the working class which you
do so affectionately they come from a
different angle and the films are not
that separate from yours it's ten years
apart and they are a world of difference
that's what's so stunning when you see
the films now back-to-back the different
approach
I was curious to see how you had a field
those dance scenarios and it does look
like a documentary in a number of ways
they were not shy with a camera that
were not afraid they were not looking at
all because I was it because I think I
mean first of all they all know Maria
because she like she said she got to
know them but you know they they are
performers you know the they they have
the life that she has meaning you know
the
of the week they have real life and then
you go here to escape real life you know
it's it's it's it's romance it's uber
romance without the complication of
romance you know it's it's it's a little
bit of what she's doing you know it's so
when we got there you know I don't
particularly remember like the shots
being very hard to set up because the
dancing is so formal and everyone's so
comfortable that it was I mean it was
almost for me it was easy because Maria
and Bethenny's had been there so often I
mean I recognize so many of these faces
that I hadn't seen but like I knew is
like oh that guy and that couple and you
know you could go to you could go to a
salon colonia week after week like we
did and it would always be a center
group of 20-30 couples that were
decouples you know and they had the word
their own wardrobe like Maria said so we
were really shooting them no one was
playing anyone something I did remember
the guy who dances with her you know the
guy she's looking for is Carmelo is a
real dancer that you found there right
did you find him there else no we
started shooting the film did I remember
that you will be American I tell it we
started shooting the film in Veracruz
known in Mexico City and we hadn't found
Carmelo because I had I had made casting
with all the actors in in Mexico and I
was so crazy about that son at the time
that none of them really Dunstan's on
the way they should so and and Maria
Roja was totally in agreement with me so
we were saying no no none of these can
be she became a real master I mean she
was and we went to Veracruz we started
shooting the film and we whenever we had
a chance at night forever we went
dancing
Maria Rohan me and we went to a dance of
the workers of the dogs dogs and we were
there and he came in Carmelo his name
was Daniel racist he came in with that
white suit with his hat with his shoes
and I just lived in Kosova Maria Maria
that's Carmelo venetus and she said yes
I think so go and ask him to dance yes I
will go and I took out my video camera
because I all the time I had I had a
yellow submarine jello video camera that
I took to the dance hall during months
and people were used that I was there
with my yellow camera and then I took
the yellow camera out because Carmelo
was there Maria asked him to dance they
started dancing I was shooting with
yellow camera and he was like who are
these two crazy women what are they
trying to do with me after the first
dance I said of course that he's the one
and I told him we were shooting a film
and he should go to the office the
production office and he laughed and
laughed he's he thought we were trying
to pick him up he didn't believe
anything until he went to the office and
then he saw it was for real I trained
him a little bit she was not good good
dialogue so I took away all the
dialogues that there were on that he
will just dance he will not speak is
that fine - Ortiz is difficult that long
take and yes they have to look into each
other and that's that's the thing that
brought me to this is he was very good
with the dancing he was very you know he
has a vanity that he has and he has
surprised and he was a very good dancer
and he was very um you know pleased to
be dancing with Maria who was a very
famous you know our theater and movie
star but in the last scene when they
danced and they looked I remember how
much he struggled to hold her gaze
because she really as an actress would
can
with this guy with all that it meant to
her and as tough as he was he said he
was it was really tough to look into her
eyes because it was so deep in such
intensity and he had fallen in love with
her yes that's a problem
what interesting thing of seeing it in
the big screen is the contrast of the a
of the color palette between Mexico City
sort of drab and the glorious colors of
the Caribbean how much did you work it I
did did you paint things for example
this one of our Scouting's
we discovered that blue that was
everywhere that we just called it a sort
of a recluse Veracruz blue because it
was you know it was just a huge that was
available in a lot of places and we must
we might have painted a few walls but we
mostly shot most of the places are the
way they are honestly right because I
wrote the script for the real places the
idea of Gris came because I loved that
so the place called the Acropolis that
is blue and has the posters and many
things were written for the real place
is the audio the Rex hotel was real just
the way it is and prostitutes lived
there prostitutes with the kids so it
was a very documentary way of working
and finding the then we decided that the
the Maria's most important dress should
be red because Veracruz was blue so she
should be dressed in red and the one
thing we painted it was the names of
some of the ships that good have been so
is he now in digital times but at the
time at the time it was a very very big
problem because they could not allow us
to change the name of any ship shoot and
then we paint you know ships name is the
license plate so we you know a ship
would be called you know Athenian
morning and we wanted to call it you
broke my heart so that was the whole
thing
and the like a tear when of the persons
in charge of production had a brilliant
idea to go to the place where they take
out the ships from the sea and they
paint them and she said there we can
change the names and we should shoot in
ships that have the names our ships that
are out of the water being serviced
because we could not paint the actual
ships but then we did the the right
framing so that by editing some ships
around the sea and the others are not
but you don't realize when she's walking
around asking sailors for were those
just real guys or to where those are
guys or our extras or just people who
was the Russian embassy to ask for
Russian I remember because when she
walks when she walks into the bar which
now has clothes right wasn't that uh
that was that famous cafeteria yes I saw
the Russian embassy they had presented
me some blonde actors in in Mexico and
said oh she looks Russian I know so I
went to the embassy and and and the the
idea that I share the cultural affairs
or whatever said yes yes but you can
have one Russian choose so I went into
the Russian embassy and I chose la
parroquia right he was a real guy man
from the embassy so when you put your
film in perspective of Mexican films you
can see your wink of the eyes too you
know some Mexican classics but you don't
go into the melodrama full speed but you
pull up pull back a little bit because
you you are doing something that it's
more romantic and maybe more nostalgic
so I was interested
in you and your sister working with the
conventions of melodrama how did that
work out yes we were we really wanted to
to make an homage to to our heritage and
to the Mexican cinema that we had seen
seen as children but of course we wanted
to subvert it to change it to the women
were completely other women from that
those films and would say totally
different things and would act
completely different and Romans would be
lived in a very different way but we
would still play the rules of the of the
Mexican melodrama to change it to say
this word subvert it but you don't have
what we will have next week here with a
more local the rich saying Garcia Diego
field we will not have that they they
really are brutal with profundo karma
see and and and and and you have a
different approach which is interesting
to see my nature I think you know it's
of course there's a big tradition of you
know melodrama in Mexico some of which
you know I mean some of it was terrible
and some of it was wonderful but also
around the 70s late 60s and 70s and 80s
just before this movie were made were
made you know melodrama was sort of put
aside and movies became much grittier
and much tougher but the female
characters were just you know they were
always being murdered or prostitutes or
you know it was just not there was there
was like knowing between you know the
the melodrama disappeared but then
things started being about prostitutes
getting murdered and you know it was
just terrible you know this this this
was one of the first films that sort of
found you know a woman who's a dreamer
who lives in a melody I mean and I'm
telling you this I didn't even know this
when we shot it this is what the movie I
saw today you know this is the melodrama
of you know it's a woman who lives in
in this dream state it's so lovely to
just go and dance and not have to you
know like it there's it life isn't messy
when she's dancing you know I think
that's just that's just wonderful it's a
it's I wouldn't even call it a feminist
movie it's a it's just a movie and about
a woman you know yeah I enjoyed it I
think the secret is to wait 25 years to
wait see the movie that you worked on no
I'm going to do it from now on
and then it's interesting to see in
Cindy her wager or your film of a few
years later that you again have now two
women on journeys but those journeys are
physical and geographical and you go
through Mexico and you pay homage to the
real people of Mexico - so is that like
the narrative that you have that it's
your interest women on the move
I don't know me maybe just I think it's
not very complicated I'm a make a
journey to make the film to write the
story to figure out what I want to talk
about and then the film comes out as a
journey also because that's the journey
I - to understand what I was really
wanting to talk about I think it has
happened to me every time I write a film
I simply try to be very very sincere in
what I am trying to tell him father I am
finding I have always from the beginning
used documentary tools and fictional
tools I think many many now that I have
a career of 30 years I think that
there's not for me that there's not a
mystery about what I do it's very clear
what my interests are and what may
my my Rami enters my obsessions my
obsession so yes I think it's time to
wrap up and anything else that you might
want to see you have given us a
delightful evening I'm very happy to
hear that I just wanted to tell you we
we were able to make the restoration of
the film only very recently we were
working very hard it was such a lovely
thing for me to have this invitation and
to know that I I was invited to come
here and show the film that it gave me a
lot of strength to fight for the
restoration of the film which was not
not all the time you see and we've been
working a few months and doing the
restoration I think many wonderful
things when were done that it was I
don't know if you saw it differently but
I think it it shines again and I think
also the sound was splendid and you know
for me you know it's been a long time
since I've done anything in film you
know it's digital has you know so it's
it's I never was one who thought you
have to pick between one or the other
but this has that beautiful look and its
own particular look and you know I think
when things work you can't imagine them
well in any other way and then Maria's
performance I mean I know it was good
but I'd forgotten you know very daring
yes so I wanted to thank this invitation
to show danceOn today here to you
because it it helped us to to make the
restoration for possible and remember
that there is this a very long beautiful
interview with her done by Luda
deportiva
in the Academy website it's worth a
watching every minute of it you will
laugh and cry and everything the
wonderful insight into your work thank
you so yeah the Kenan was pleased to
have you both here tonight
[Applause]
you